what is up guys my name is Chandra
welcome to episode 18 of 3d and
programming in Java alrighty now I've
been sick for like the past week and a
half so I actually wake in one day at
the moment but um it's getting there so
I couldn't release an episode on Sunday
and I'm really sorry about that I'm
actually still sick so I might my voice
is a bit different you might not pick it
up over this uh you know not very high
quality microphone but yeah my voice is
different and I cough a lot so I might
be coughing throughout this video and
I'm sorry but hey you know I wanted to
release this before Christmas and today
is the 22nd of December so I thought you
know let's give it a run ok so this is
not gonna be a long half hour tutorial
because I don't even know how long how
long I can talk I've been avoiding
talking for like the past week because
if I talk like this from one one minute
I just start coughing it's been like
over a week there so I should be good to
go
um mmm ok Wow ok let's go right there we
go ok let's let's get started alrighty
and I don't know what it is either like
people asking me I don't know like I've
got no other symptoms I feel fine I
don't have a fever or anything my throat
is sore and I my voice sounds different
but apart from that like I really don't
have any other symptoms I feel fine
I feel really lazy though um that's one
thing but hey it's the holidays so I
guess I'm allowed to radio let's get
started ok so I render thread ok
basically what we're going to do today
is we're gonna talk about the beginnings
walls and objects and sort of that
because at the moment if you look at
this all we've got is just like a plane
like field basically we don't have any
like objects on the field right now ok
so I'm basically I want to talk to you
guys about the basis of actually popping
stuff in front of us at the moment ok
when I'm actually going to like we're
just going to talk about the concept of
this and how it's going to work and how
will eventually replace like what we
what we will create here with like
textures and sprites and 2d objects so
2d objects by the way if you don't fit
in or 2d of what the difference is
between 2d objects and 3d objects 2d
objects or sprites as I guess they
called they will they'll look at you
wherever whatever angle you're looking
at them from so if I was looking at them
from like I don't know here or whatever
and I'd
rotating around like that they would all
they would always be facing the camera
so if I rotate it if I move like this
basically if I try a look at them from
another angle they'll actually rotate to
always look at the camera
3d objects don't 3d 3d objects stay
static and when you rotate when you like
not rotate but when you try to see it it
see them from a different angle they'll
show their other angle because it's 3d
object and has that data okay so we will
be importing 3d objects you know like
walls like buildings like guns like a
bunch of stuff basically character
models maybe I don't know I haven't
actually done that before for this type
of game engine for a you know for a non
opengl thing but our 3d models aren't
that hard to import as our 2d sprites
will probably do 2d first but we're not
gonna do any other today um what we're
gonna do today is talk about I guess the
concept alrighty so um let's talk about
let's talk about how I scene is set up
as well
um nothing I've got everything fine um
yeah alright let's just jump into this
alright okay so um let's start by in our
floor method excuse me um just before
the end by the way if you just if you
want to see what the end of the floor
method is if you put your yeah what is
this thing called like the type II thing
like the curves I don't even know what
that's called now anyone know that's
called the little thing that shows you
where you're typing I I don't know maybe
it's just a memory blank but if you put
it after the the curly bracket then I'm
it will actually highlight the the
corresponding end curly bracket here so
let's type before that so just make sure
that you're before the end of your floor
method but obviously after the what is
this after the whole rendering logic and
just move this chord out of the way as
well it's kind of not letting me type
here already um right okay so what we
want to do here is let's just say okay
let's just render a pixel to the screen
right now okay um I'll just type it out
here so you guys can see alrighty so
pixels excuse me okay I want to be doing
this throughout the whole video guys
just letting
you know you guys wanted me to do this
and I want to do this but hey currently
do it okay so um expert yeah okay all
right so our pixels thing I think we've
established that our pixels thing is
what renders pixels to the screen and
what we've done is we've rendered pixels
and then what we've done is we've
assigned a texture to those pixels so
here we're going to sort of sort of do
the same thing already oh this is
embarrassing anyway so ten plus let's
just draw it a 10 by 10 so that's going
to be like the coordinates and we'll
just multiply that by the width was it
equal to like 1 or whatever for now um
hmm sorry if we if we run this what
you'll see is like a little pixel I'm
sorry guys I really am
and if you can actually see right next
to the FPS counter you'll probably won't
be able to see this unless this isn't
like 1080p on like a 1080p or higher
monitor or like a really big screen but
it cuz it's only one pixel but we've
rendered a pixel that's to the left and
a bit higher than the FPS counter so
it's basically called in a 10 by 10 and
you can see that and we can actually
what we can do as well as we can just
assign the color by changing this too
that'll be like teal I think I stressed
all this all right no it's not oh crap
obviously not I've changed the wrong
thing that should be teal yeah you can
see it um it's in the top right top left
corner
so we've rented one pixel to the screen
at the moment and I guess they've not
done another way to show you this more
clearly is um throw a bunch of these and
quickly go in and change this to this
and you can see a line now yeah I'm not
going to go further in but there's like
a line maybe you can see that one I
don't know but if you do it on your own
computers than you'll you'll be able to
see it um and what that's doing is
that's rendering pixels to the screen
which is great and stuff but what we
actually want to do here is we want to
sort of
well we want to be able to render like a
wall basically fixins and oh okay I
apologize right okay so what we
basically want to do is say that okay
we've got like this system here let's
pop a wall over there let's pop a wall
that which is made out of pixels
obviously and then we'll assign a um or
water so well sound like a texture to it
and then that'll be like our wall of
trees right someone's calling me right
now I'm just going to go ahead and
reject that call because I'm doing
something much more serious here I don't
even know who that was like it's a nun
like it's not it's not a blocked number
but I have him as a contact anyway
I'm important um they didn't leave a
voicemail okay okay
alrighty sorry about that um so
basically all we want to do is assign
like those pixels later on we want to
assign a texture to them so let's go
ahead and um and sup so we've got this
wonderful okay
what we'll use is something called
random okay we've used this before and
I'll just use it here to show you guys
how the system works
um right or is it just trying to find
what we use it a little gloomy and
screen wouldn't move okay yep okay so we
used random right here to actually
generate a random number of pixels that
we did in Episode one for that I think
it was episode 5 I'm not 100 percent
sure four or five maybe even six I'll
say five there I think we did in five
we're going to do it again so let's just
import around random random equals new
random and up I let's just terminate
this for now we'll import it and and
sort this out okay right so over here
all we want to do is make a few doubles
okay let's make um let's just call them
X X then that'll deal because we've
already got X is already taken and I
don't want if I don't want to get you
guys confusing hit with anything else I
will just set that to ran random dot
next double
and we'll just copy it paste this and
let's just paste it three times I
apologize
alrighty let's just let's just post it
three times so one for YY one put Zed
Zed and obviously one for X X so X is
going to be our like horizontal y is
going to be our vertical and see Zella
Zed actually I should be saying that I'm
Australian I live in Australia anyway um
Zed is our depth alrighty
and let's actually set our depth to
something like one at the moment okay
because we want to be like one the idea
here guys is that we have like a number
and the further this is the further away
from the camera this is from you know
from the player it is basically um so
we'll test this out in a bit I will make
over okay we'll make two integers we'll
call one of them um let's give it a name
this will be the X rendering thing well
the actual X pixel I guess I'll call it
expressible and we'll add a cost of an
end to this because we'll be using X X
and stuff that's double obviously this
is a double but we want to convert it
into an integer I think I've done this
before I probably have I definitely have
actually I'm in fact ah here it is right
here
what this what does ant in brackets does
before it is it saying that whatever
comes next
whatever okay
whatever za whatever's in these brackets
convert it from whatever it is so from a
double basically because we'll be using
xx and YY and Zed Zed convert whatever
is in these brackets into an integer
okay so if it's 2.2 it'll become two
okay because we're using doubles here
and we want to convert them into an
integer so let's just say okay so go X X
divided by our depth and we'll multiply
that by height and remember because our
height is sort of inside our with will
divide by two for now because I've
worked out those calculations beforehand
as well plus width and we'll divide it
by two again
actually let's just leave it like
without the divided by two and
show you guys what that looks like
because the whole thing about this is
just playing with it really it's a lot
of fun like you don't need to be a Java
expert or anything - or like a game
programmer to really work out how this
stuff works in terms of you know get it
to look right because it's just
adjusting numbers and just seeing what
that looks like so I will do the same
thing obviously but for YY I'm not going
to copy and paste I'll retie before you
guys accept let's just um multiply up by
height and we'll add height to it so
we're not gonna because um if you go up
here you can see that basically the way
the what the reason I'm doing this is
because I'm y is right here right so if
you can see this our X is inside our
height so that's why we use height here
and then here we use with because well
it's the X which is with and here we use
Y because Y is the width the height so
it's fairly it's fairly um it's going to
grab blueberry mmm it's fairly
self-explanatory um now we want to
basically set up the rendering and we're
going to set up the actual rendering
thing as an F statement so let's just
I'll set it off first okay so if our x
pixel is greater than or equal to zero
and so we're saying that oh I did this
we'll fill it in Matt I think I did this
before would be in control
yeah same thing here you know if these
if all these conditions are met do this
alright so if X P if X pixel is
basically greatings it so if it's not
because we don't want to render pixels
off the screen right we'd only use up
calculations and processing power to
render stuff that's not actually going
to appear in front of us right which is
why we're saying that only render these
pixels if they are on the screen so if
it's greater than or equal to zero
because zero is to look ordinate
obviously and you know same thing for y
pixel so if Y pixel is greater than or
equal to zero
and also so okay so basically what we've
done here is we've pixel oh haha that's
funny no um well it is kind of funny but
that's not the point
um right okay so basically what we've
done here is we've said that let me just
bring this up real quick hopefully we
won't crash didn't good basically what
we've done here is we've said that if
there's aroma this is zero zero there
let me just sorry let me just this is
really hard to explain with having a
mouse pointer so I'm just going to go in
here and where's our um so occurs a
blank I'm just going to comment out this
line so that we actually see our cursor
okay so this is kinda Smoot okay screw
Frick okay this is so it's really hard
to explain with why is why they're two
windows why do I have two windows I must
not have terminated the other one okay
right yeah um let's just go on to Rona
3d I'm literally just going to comment
out rotation and set it to zero at the
moment cuz it's distracting me all right
I guess okay so this point is zero zero
right and there you can see the pixel
this point is zero zero and that's 10 10
and that is 800 600 600 800 comma 600
that's the cordon um what we've done
here is we've said already if if the
x-coordinate is basically greater than
zero
right so if it's great if it's equal to
zero which is like right here oh it's
anywhere greater than zero then go ahead
and render if it's less than zero so if
the pixel is located somewhere over here
at like minus 100 by by 400 or in terms
of coordinates then don't render don't
take up CPU usage graphical power or
whatever don't take our processing power
figuring out what that pixel is doing or
what textures applied to it or whatever
if it's not on the screen stop rendering
it basically and same like and we've
done the same thing that's what with Y
as well we've said that if Y is only
randa if Y is greater than or equal to
zero so if Y is off the screen somewhere
here don't render it we've done that so
we've done it for these two corners but
we haven't done it for here what if
what if Y is like greater than 600 or
greater than our resolution or X is a is
greater than our resolution you know
don't render either we don't want to
render if it's somewhere over here
either
so um I hope that clear that up okay so
all we need to do here is say okay so
that's cool but also don't render if
it's greater than what it needs to be so
if X pixel is group is less than with so
again only render if it's less than with
and our width at the moment is 800 so if
it's located at 810 don't render it
because it's not going to be on the
screen so it's lesson with or that's not
all
and if it's if Y pixel is obviously less
night all right so what we're saying is
and let's just copy and paste this I'm
actually just going to cotton paste in
control X control there and every time
you see like me format the code like go
like that
that's I'm just pressing control shift F
or command shift F if you're on a Mac
actually is it come out I think I might
be actually control should air for my
Mac as well I'm not sure I don't know I
don't code much on a Mac I just use that
for like for film work basically a
live-action video editing you know with
Final Cut installer that assume there
isn't actually have a MacBook Pro but um
I only use Windows for coding that's
just the way I roll alrighty so um so
yeah okay so now we've said that you
know only if if the pixel is located on
the screen
do you actually render it so if we run
this you actually won't see anything at
the moment but at some point okay so
radio so we got this going on now let's
go ahead and and basically put all this
into a for loop so that we get a bunch
of pixel so it for okay so as a lot
basically what we're saying is I don't
know we'll do it I'll do it
ah we'll do it ten thousand times we'll
see how much that lowers the framerate
and we'll see if we can do it more
I just closed off this full loop as well
right over here okay okay so we're not
actually getting any pixels up at the
moment as you can as you can tell all
righty
pixel greater than 0 y x squared 0 all
right so that's cool okay let's just
let's add rotation back in um all righty
let's uh let's figure this out all right
okay so um what we've done here where
are we okay so um cool we've done that
now let's um let's actually set these
instead of 10 actually when I set that
equal to pixels
okay I just have to take a little break
for a drink by the way guys that's all
I'm back right now okay so I'm a thing
at the moment is uh okay so this is out
Z and we can't actually see our pixels
at the moment probably cuz they're out
of the screen actually let's just divide
this by 2 and this as well alrighty so
okay we see our pixels and they're
moving for some reason yeah okay so it's
right it's regenerating them they
shouldn't be doing that let's just it's
really good stuff here okay let's just
grab random and pop it just for this so
that it is actually in in the method and
that should stop it from not in the code
as well um all right okay um yeah so
it's just okay there we go
good that uh that are that stopped it
from well going crazy and stuff alrighty
so I'm alright
okay so let's just disable rotation
again um where is rotation here it is
okay
so what we go now is basically you can
see that if I don't actually rotate or
move you can say that well well what's
happening at the moment is that this is
I don't worry about this really thick
line that's just because it's that's the
way it's rendering don't worry about
that we will fix up later but um that's
zero zero right and that's like the end
of this thing and you can see that
basically it's conforming to that and
what what happens is if we actually um
if we come down here and move this to
like one then what's going to happen is
it's going to move it up to this one now
that's because it's sort of treating
that as one block so it's treating for
these squares basically is one thing so
if we put it to 1.5 I'm really sorry
about this um if we put it to 1.5 then
what that's going to do is it's going to
pop it up here let's just save that
works deprecated obviously did you can
see that it's it's up here at 1.5
Ronia and um same if we put it to 2.5
it's going to jump to that one so you
can see now what I'm about to do is I'm
just going to bring it back by one block
every time so we can sort of move our
wall like that and is obviously you know
you could put it two to five and that
will be in the middle of these two and
seven five would be in the middle of
those two and you can do stuff like that
so don't feel like you're actually like
like it's minecraft and you'll conform
to using stuff that's one by one you
know in terms of blocks and one by one
by one
um because it's what's three so yeah
that's fine don't worry about that um
all right and similarly of course we're
also let's pop that too
we're also like we've sort of got
different like things as well if you
displace this by minus one right on the
X that's going to move it - one that way
obviously it - it's going to move it
that way what's going to keep you on
that way three it's going to be you know
more that way so aim was like plus zero
is going to be here you know plus one is
one over there plus two plus three
probably won't even be on the screen
yeah okay and you can see that how that
has sort of works
um let's come up here and okay so
forward is our right okay forward is our
um let's make it walk automatically
because at the moment was obviously not
actually in place here but um
let's just delete this and set it to
game time um and divide by 100 point
zero so they're going to do for us all
right okay let's actually take the
remainder of that so I put a percentage
sign here and then I'm divide it by like
I don't know twenty point zero so it's
going to pop back every now and then and
grab the forward variable let's just pop
the forward variable right over here so
I'm will subtract it obviously because
if we added it's actually going to go
the opposite way so you can see it sort
of darts off that way we want to
subtract that let's go this way
and okay yeah that's again it's going
way too fast let's divide by like
sixteen or something and that was
perfect like that so yeah okay sixteen
is actually perfect you can see that it
stays with the thing at the moment um
all right all righty okay
I've just been coughing non-stop I'm
sorry guys but uh yeah again close this
okay so we've got a hero down that's
awesome um okay that's that's pretty
much it guys that's okay I I said this
wouldn't be half an hour long but it's
like 24 minutes at the moment but um hey
um more blueberries by the way they're
really good um anyway it's summer here
in Australia if you're wondering it's
like 30 degrees outside here in
Melbourne well not really but um anyway
I actually know what temperature is
outside I haven't been outside in a few
days cuz I just I've been up to it but
um alright so one last thing I want to
show you guys is what we've done here
and let's just run her a bit more cuz um
oh that's a lot that's ah it's not
actually that much is that that's right
why I can't see properly that's through
it yeah it's only 250,000 you can see
how that's quite a bit and the frame
rate dropped as well but um I just round
up 100,000
um that's actually quite a bit okay
anyway so you can see how that sort of
works and let's let's just take this
full loop this entire thing and let's
copy and paste it right over here and
let's also move it so well off that 1 by
minus 1 because there now I've got 2 and
I don't know this feel so much let's set
this to like 50000 or something or even
20,000 like it's actually like it's
almost like a wall so it's like 1
million that I go got a solid wall now
10 million ha ha
12 frames per second ok that's fine
we'll set it to 20,000 and let's just
grab this and we'll copy and paste it
again
and this minus 1 at the moment let's pop
this 2 minus 1 minus 1 and this 2 minus
1 here and then nothing here so what I'm
doing here is you can see that basically
what we've proven here is that our thing
is two blocks high and that's you can
see that that's peeking at the ceiling
here and that's the floor so our thing
is two blocks I and you can see that our
frame rate is still holding up pretty
well and we're still that's good to know
anyway so yeah you can see how that this
is basically the basis what we'll talk
about next time is actually replacing
this well probably actually because this
isn't actually matched in with our
movement so if we move this isn't gonna
it's not it's not like it I want to use
film terms but it's not really gonna be
motion tracks to our footage I guess so
that's just plain filmmaking talk right
there
but this thing isn't going to be stuck
to our pixels as you saw before I'll
move but this act will actually move
with the camera it's not going to be
stuck to an actual proportional spot in
3d time 3d space so not 3d time 3d space
so yeah we might do that but we'll also
talk about actually applying textures
this those things to these things and
not and even rotating em to it that way
and talk about building cubes and maybe
even collision detection and stuff like
that so all that stuff will come after
Christmas
okay after New Year's probably--if and I
want to take a break for a while and I
think I might live stream anyway because
I always enjoy live streaming and well
that doesn't require much effort at all
on my part um such as talking for half
an hour non-stop about programming which
is fun as well obviously but okay yes so
I'm sorry really sorry about this
tutorial guys um I guess this proves
that I am sick I'm not just avoiding
this obviously I don't think I don't
think any of you guys actually thought
that I was but um yeah thank you for all
the messages about getting well soon I
appreciate it and that's pretty much it
guys so this is a 2 block by 2 block
thing oh actually one more thing before
we go actually let's um let's copy paste
one more time but let's put this to like
two or something yeah you can see
there's now one behind it and um if we
grab all of this we'll grab all three
are actually which one is this one let's
set this to zero if we grab three of
these and this will probably make it lag
but um grab three of these and set all
of these to two and feel free to play
around with this like it's a lot of fun
- and - then you can see that we've sort
of got two walls now we've got one
behind this wall and and it's all
running cool and sort of that so and
it's running a lot slower but hey so um
yeah so we've sought about two walls now
and you can see they're really they're
conforming appropriate they're working
and everything is awesome so yeah we'll
talk about making objects like this in
3d space next time which will be after
New Year's as well if you want to ask me
questions or whatever honestly when I
livestream I'll just post a video to
YouTube saying that I'm limes that I'm
live-streaming so you guys can go check
that out at twitch.tv for such the
channel it'll you'll see the video um
when it's live what I am live streaming
but otherwise follow me on Twitter
that's probably the best place to get
updated I've got a Facebook page as well
but um you know that's I don't actually
I don't like it as much as Twitter so
Twitter Facebook
last room and uh I hope you guys have a
very Merry Christmas and a Happy New
Year and yeah and we'll jump into this
in 2012 so see you guys later bye